[Applause]
what do you think about what happened
with the
the the the paul's and floyd mayweather
was it staged of course to a certain
extent but then there was some [ __ ] that
was real like
like floyd was leaning into it when he
was running around afterwards like i'm
gonna kill that [ __ ] i'ma kill
him like
he floyd knows the cameras are on and
he's gonna charge us up cause he's like
the more promo we do today the less i
have to do until the fight yeah
if this [ __ ] flop then he got to do
another promo thing he's got to go and
do some more stuff and
they had an amazing promo i'll tell you
this you can't
say jake paul made his career off of
logan paul if anybody ever said that
before that's done
yeah because logan is getting a lot of
help from jake right now i mean jake
jake really really stole the the show
man he did he mainly
stole the show he [ __ ] stole the show
and it's so funny man because like
i really like logan yeah like because
he's so [ __ ] likable like yeah even
off air just talking to logan
he is a good guy and genuinely likeable
like nice kind person
i mean i remember asking about [ __ ]
nfts and she's like yeah he just
immediately hooked me up with his nft
thing randomly hooked me up with this
kid in tennessee
he's like yo this is good for you guys
to meet just out of nowhere yeah
genuinely good right
um so i think it's hard for him to play
heal
yep he had one time in his life where he
did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and it was out of character like at a
character meeting
his character i think is more profitable
when he's likable okay because that is
closer to who he is
okay jake can play the [ __ ] out of the
heel
and ain't nothing more interesting than
eel yeah floyd
has been so interesting his whole life
since he started becoming a heel
conor incredibly interesting as a heel
it is hard to be
the face yeah i mean think about
characters in wrestling or anything else
that are a face and likable even the
great tom brady
is best when he's poking fun when he's
being petty
when he's talking [ __ ] when he's leaning
in to heal yeah
nobody want to care about that tom brady
oh we worked really hard we passed
everybody we did all this [ __ ] [ __ ] that
we care about him posting pictures of
the team that got their ass bus saying
talk [ __ ] again or whatever the [ __ ] he
was saying
you know how you i don't know if this
applies but in wrestling when you want
to make a guy popular
you'll make him a heel first and then
everybody hate him and then you flip
it's easier yeah it's an easier road to
popularity
yeah that i don't suggest that logan
plays even though i've come on this
podcast and i'm like it's easier if he
plays the heel blah blah
it will be easier if he wants to just
make money and then this is a big fight
he just goes full [ __ ] if he goes full
tiki torch all right
this fight would make 200 million
dollars yeah but then what do you do the
rest of your career the kid's still
young
yeah i think you're gonna make less
because you're not the heel and it's
harder to sell
but i think it's a better long play for
your career yes
if for whatever reason i do not see this
happening at all but if for whatever
reason he ends up beating floyd
yeah the guy's [ __ ] the guy could be
president yeah
the guy could be [ __ ] present imagine
not [ __ ] rocky
that's logan paul he he beats floyd
he beats floyd rocky got a statue he
couldn't even read
he's a full [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy okay
imagine a well-spoken guy goes and
fights against essentially
the apollo creed of the real world floyd
mayweather imagine he wins that fight
and he's well spoken and funny and
charismatic what could that guy not do
the [ __ ] got a statue
a real statue for a movie character that
is kind of all right i see that
the not [ __ ] yep also aiding asians is
an all-time high
yeah that's the only bad thing that he's
done in his career i think a lot of
people forgive it right now you go
i think they might i really think they
might now is the [ __ ] time
run run for if he beats floyd he has to
run for office he has to
the rock and logan paul and i'm sorry
rocky but you got to be vp
you got to be vp vp slash security
debugging
vp slash security let logan do it no
logan's the face
logan is going to be
then he eventually runs we're like oh
this ain't that bad well here's what's
so genius about their strategy to let
jake be the heel yeah
is now he's he's still doing promo for
whatever his next fight is
that's great and logan is letting him do
promo for this fight so they're getting
promo two fights out with this one thing
run with it boys yeah it's brilliant
[ __ ] him run with it brilliant i mean
logan be like oh god check my brother
that's such a logan interested
in seeing logan and floyd or do you
rather want to see jake and floyd
i think i think i think we always want
to see the heel
in anything yeah right but i am more
interested in logan floyd now just
because of that practice
yeah and also the [ __ ] talk like
like the [ __ ] talk was kind of wild
remember
floyd said something to him like uh you
know don't disrespect uh
you know japan or something like that
like you disrespected japan and logan
was like you disrespected your wife
or something like that like i don't know
like they were going they were deep cut
going back and forth
and it was enough to get me kind of into
it i was like okay i need to see that
yeah yeah i only saw the fight so i
didn't because yeah i only saw the fight
and i'm not necessarily interested in
logan and floyd but i'm a little more
interested for sure
and i'm definitely more interested in
jake so you got two fights where you
piqued interest
yeah yeah they and you saw jake's tattoo
the gotcha hat thing
yeah i mean i mean this guy was selling
hats that said gotcha hat
within an hour before he even took the
hat the guy planned to take the hat
like he understands the game this guy
understands the game and he doesn't care
if you like him or not
he gets to make the decision what will
get the most clicks
without considering how he will be
viewed in that decision
yeah that is valuable that is liberating
the superpower
exactly because think about we could all
say the craziest [ __ ]
like i know how to get the most [ __ ]
clicks on that chappelle conversation
yeah just go in trash make it look like
chappelle's just trying to undercut hate
like
we could click bait the [ __ ] out of that
if we want but it's not authentic it's
not real
yeah okay that guy knows how to get
clicks and can lean into whatever
direction
and if you underestimate him you think
he's stupid i'm telling you you're the
stupid one and he's gonna take your ass
to the [ __ ] bank yep